VISERYS TARGARYEN: I have only ever defended you.
DAEMON TARGARYEN: Ten years you have been king and
yet not once have you asked me to be your hand.
VISERYS: Why would I do that?
DAEMON: Because I am your brother.
MATT SMITH: I play Prince Daemon
Targaryen. He’s the sort of Prince of the realm
really and he’s very much an outsider. He treads
on the outskirts of everything and everyone
DAEMON: Much of King’s Landing is seen by
the smallfolk as lawless and terrifying.
MATT: Daemon’s all swords and knives really.
He’s also a dragonrider. He
has a dragon called Caraxes.
He has a great affiliation and love and admiration
for his brother, the King, but there’s a sort of
deep, dark history that surrounds them.
DAEMON: I’ve only ever spoken the truth
and the blood of the dragon runs thick.
MATT: He’s a sort of reluctant one. I think he’s
interested in chaos, I think he survives in chaos
quite well. It’s not as though he wants to be
king of the land or any of that, I think he’s
just pretending and trying to make everyone angry.
House of the Dragon is about war, love,
rebellion and deceit. In many ways it
sort of feels at times like a big tragedy,
constantly waiting to sort of get worse.